for you saying something without
knowledge you don't
know brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that1 is used to buy food
or bricks or whatever to help the people
in Gaza but then just imagine this
amazing D that you want to do but we
turn it into a moneymaking machine how
they take your money and the money that
we are going to put in in this walk this
building and every single time the money
generated from that W that building is
going to go to our Palestinian brothers
and sisters for the next 20 30 40 50 60
100 150 years and this will be a form of
true click the link below and
donate brothers and sisters and dear
friends Ramadan muak hope you guys have
an amazing time this is the month of the
year that you get closer to to Allah
subh than you could ever be before this
is my 11th year of Ramadan brother and
sisters right now today I'm going to be
doing a live appeal for our and do an
open Q&A for Ramadan prepare for us go
to the live in we're going to be live
today and many other days inah join us
and get involved we go through Allah's
names reading the Quran had water
challenge I do ice buff challenge if
people donate to allow us to teach
people how to playay Salah let's get
straight into the video in we're going
to watch I've been meaning to do a
reaction video for a long time he seems
like a young man a lot of people think
he's related to me he's my cousin or
something or Min Al whatever you want to
call that for matter let's watch this
video aldah cuz I'm not going I'm going
to be honest aldah there's so many
beautiful character traits about him
that you SE in this video but sadly
there are some dangerous things that he
says even though people don't really
realize but we'll dissect that inshah so
um I love him for the sake of Allah
subhana may Allah bless him he seems
like he is Kurdish from his accent I can
see like you know Turks and Kurds look
alike but he seems like he's Kurdish
himself uh or he might be seran I don't
know for that matter but let's listen to
the video inshallah and let's see what
he has to say and his reaction to that
girl who tries to interrupt him
foreign
speech foreign
speech
foreign
fore
foreign speech
speech
foreign
speeech
[Music]
for so just want to stop there I don't
know what that woman was talking about
first she was like so she said at the
beginning anyone that votes for T Eran
Eran is not one of us and she says there
is Allah above us so she's saying fear
God that don't vote for Edan okay and
then she says okay it seems like she's
talking against him but she goes this
boy is talking so much truth saying this
boy speaking so much truth but if turkey
has made this boy the way he
is then something to do with rean blame
like I don't know if she's praising him
I don't know if she's cussing him I
don't know if she's indirect I have no
idea what she's talking about um maybe
she's on a menstrual cycle I don't know
I she she made absolutely no sense I'm
going to trying to be rude I don't know
what she I don't if she's praising him
having a go at him I don't know if that
matter but let's let's let's carry on
forget like I I even like the fact that
this one thing that you see that he
doesn't look at her yeah Al so it shows
that he has deep inated aldah connection
with Allah subhana T that he lowers his
Gates which is very important Brothers
at this time in Ramadan it's a reminder
to myself first is one of the big
biggest weaknesses for us men but the
fact that he didn't even look her way so
I really commend him for that and I love
his Zeal and his his love for the de it
really really I'll be honest with you
amazing when I see young people who have
this Zeal for the dean where like I love
that but there's a few things he say was
trou was troubling but let's Carry On
[Music]
In
foree
forign
fore spech
foreign
speech
foree
fore
[Music]
foree
foreign okay so uh like I said before he
made some really good points Etc you
know I love the Zeal for his Dean but
this point of saying that to vote in a
democratic state or to get involved in
vote makes you a mus ORF is absolutely
uh it is not true yes there are some
people might hold their opinion but to
say that there is B that there's
absolute consensus that e myself as a
Muslim and I look at two parties let's
say labor and conservative yeah and even
now I I believe that there's not I
believe not to vote it's better not to
vote not because of the sh element I
just believe it does nothing that's why
I believe personally I I had I held a
different opinion before but you can see
it doesn't really mean anything yeah but
again for those who believe that for
example the H that rule governorship and
rulership for is only for Allah subhana
wa tala no muslim would ever disagree
with that any Muslim that says I prefer
democracy of the Shar is a c yes but
he's not saying that he's saying anybody
that votes yeah so this is where the
problematic issue comes because he's
making it seem as if anybody votes like
for example if we have two candidates
one is going to make the lives of
Muslims easier yes or it's a gradual
process for us to have better rights as
Muslims in in in in the UK whatever for
that matter and if Muslims have that
power to get rid of these individuals
100% in Islam we look at the lesser of
two evils how to avert evil like the
prophet peace upon said the lowest form
of IM is to take something harmful out
the way so we are looking at
holistically the harmful things so as
long as as Muslims we know we want the
Shar that is what we want that is what
we love period but we are getting
involved in this democratic election not
because we believe that they should
govern above Allah's law never but the
fact that we looking at the less of two
evils albani even albani he did not say
it
is he and many other Scholars if I'm not
mistaken mean I can't remember one of
them as well they said in a situation
where the Muslims are facing where they
have the less of two harms they have to
get involved yes to our job is to what
so he quotes
yamah y yeah it's very iron because Yu
Alam was the governor of a leadersh he
was a governor under rulership not under
Shar why because obviously if him doing
that it was better than somebody else
him governing and as a prophet of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala so it is better and a
gradual process like for example Allah
subhana wa tala when he talks about the
sahab drinking alcohol it's a gradual
process yes we're talking about and that
alcohol is different I understand that
the point is what we cannot come and say
that anybody that votes becomes a CAF
because this this is this is an extreme
view a lot of brothers some brothers
hold which it can be their opinion
that's good but to now negate the other
side and say they're C that's another
thing and another thing is for that
matter is for example ignorance there
might be people who there are people who
are ignorant they might not know so you
cannot come and see somebody who's
bowing down to something and you have to
ask them do you understand what are you
doing here is a form of I it's a form of
worship and you're doing to the are you
doing it you need to clarify ask him
does he know yes so there's so many
elements the way this young boy is
talking like I said I love is
zealousness love the love he has for
Allah the de I understand but what he's
saying is sadly ble not true it is not
true if he holds that
opinion he can but then you're going to
do that means everybody in Turkey all
the Muslim nations who are involved in
uh democracy um they all everyone's a CF
it's a chain reaction
of you know chain yes this person if he
does that is a cfir therefore they do it
they all cfir they the um blood is halal
and the chain reac continues so for him
to declare there's millions of Muslims
in Turkey who know that H is for Allah
and they prefer the Shar but they are
doing uh voting because they believe
erdogan is a better candidate than
before because before you kind wear
hijabs Etc they are like rather we have
him in power than have some scumbag ET
and again look I'm not a fan of Eran at
all yes with the treat of the CDs and
what's going on Etc I be very very clear
for that matter at all yes what the CDs
of persecution going on I'm not a fan of
I lot people talk about pal Ians and we
should but sadly turkey does the same to
the Cs you know not in the same manner
but still so this is very important for
us to touch upon so I would say in a
nutshell that this is why we should be
careful the young people to please do
not talk about matters that is above
your head this is the biggest phenomenal
we have young people zealous who love
the dean talking matters of Halal andam
and then he talks about the companion
who when he asked he mentioned that yeah
uh I for his name yeah
ad I'm not mistaken yes and he said oh
and he said that um they used to make
halam yes because he said did you not
take them when they used to worship your
rabbis he said how do we never worship
our rabbis he said did you not take what
they said Halal is halal and Haram is
Haram he said yeah and that's how you
used to worship them well then if you
look at the matter now this young boy
he's falling into this why because he's
now talking about matters of Hal and
Haram and it is a big big sin major sin
on the levels of sh it's it's it's like
doing
um what is why because you're talking
without knowledge you're saying
something without knowledge you don't
know you are quoting a few eyes here and
there and then you're talking without
knowledge my brother I love you may
Allah bless you I love your Dean I love
the way you carry yourself lowering your
gaze the love for the dean but don't
talk don't talk about matters that is
way above your head inshallah so many
people who watched this and loved him I
love him as well it's Ramadan and may
Allah preserve him and make give him a
better understanding of religion a
better understanding a beneficial
knowledge not just any knowledge in and
protect him against shatan may Allah
make him a scholar that's all I say in
but brothers and sisters please let's be
very careful inshallah um watching these
videos inspirational videos but at the
same time what the message is saying is
dangerous and he should not fall into
something that he's warning us against
uh till next
time goodbye